the Joe Rogan experience Robert II leave
us or up sorry uh the other that the
Union guy uh
there's delicious grant grant grant but
had a drinking problem but then was like
oh and he probably have from PTSD you
know and he's he's just telling that
story was such kind of emotional depth
of it's cool it's nice to watch that
instead of read it sometimes yeah I
don't think any of us are ever gonna be
able to truly understand what it was
like to live without television without
radio without cell phones and war like
what and then war inside the same
continent with other people that are
supposed to be just like you that speak
the same language yeah that you run the
risk of on hey get hey Gary yeah if you
live in like [ __ ] Virginia on the
border you could know the person who's
acing you sure and be like best of luck
to Gary I yeah I hope I do and don't get
you I don't know what the thing I was
reading this article to about how many
murders took place after the war was
settled where right like for people like
hey you know we're not done bro
yeah you killed my whole [ __ ] family
yeah they're like cool Lincoln we're
good yeah we're not good but after after
what would seem like a lifetime of that
sort of witnessing that and doing that
and watching things that you recognize
as injustice the idea of someone getting
stuck in the blame and and as a best
Vendetta and that I can I can see that I
but you see how that's really it's
probably why we're still having problems
now it's definitely some part of it
right yeah it's like my great great
great great told me yeah you know when
people are sort of like dipped in that
kool-aid of because it my great great
great great great felt this way mmm-hmm
I'm supposed to to because yeah we're
related so and sort of empowered by the
success that he's had in business and
seeing how he could change the world and
his businesses I said how about you and
I he saw what do you mean and so will
use your money and my I and will make
films and the first well then I you know
so I'm jumping careers at this stage I'm
going from
fairly successful you know still
photographer really busy to a career
where he had really no business doing it
I never really made a film before not
even really a short film and so I'm you
know nervous I'm feeling sort of full of
myself like I'm gonna start this great
career we're down the Caribbean on a
boat and my kid starts with Jim on
vacation with our families and my kids
starts playing on the beach with another
kid it happens to be Steven Spielberg's
kid so Steven comes over onto the boat
to meet Jim and I he he made Jurassic
Park using Jim's computers with you know
Silicon Graphics and after I had Steven
alone for a few seconds I said you have
any advice for a first-time filmmaker he
said you said yeah never make a movie
involving boats or animals oh great
yeah of course the first film we did was
the cove but these these are you're not
you don't have actors and special
effects and boats and animals it's just
a part of the story it's not like you're
like with him I think when he's meeting
like jaws exactly yeah because you know
you have to match shots especially all
that but it has its own set of you know
trying to keep a the horizon level on a
boat you don't want to give it the
audience and seasickness and but you
know I would add to that like don't do a
movie where people want to kill you
because when we did the cove it was you
know was exciting but dangerous work
yeah I mean they made these claims like
all the sudden people got stronger and
faster and more endurance like there's
no evidence to support that there's no
evidence other than there are anecdotal
statements of what they did there's no
one has ever put anyone on a vegan diet
and then run them through extreme
endurance tests and found a significant
increase in vo2 max or muscle strength
or any of those things none of this has
ever been done so if it's if it's true
anecdotally for these people it would've
been really interesting if there was
some actual data to go with that where
they showed studies right I mean we have
James talking about his ability to do
the battle ropes but all of a sudden he
could do an hour and before he could
only do 10 minutes well I find that
really hard to believe that you gained
50 minutes of your battle rope time just
from ropes and if that was the only
thing in the film
found hard to believe you know I'd have
to let it go I mean the guy's an athlete
he's an amazing athlete he was a great
fighter
he's got fantastic endurance is
excellent martial arts technique I would
just buy it at face level or at face
value but there's a lot of those there's
a lot and then I mean we can go through
it and talk about I mean there's that
problem which is there's no
peer-reviewed evidence to back that up
but even the anecdotal evidence is a
little shaky is when we start to talk
about some of the athletes in the film
and there are also examples of athletes
outside of the film who you know switch
to a vegan diet and we look and see what
happened to them after they did that the
problem here is something that I call
the vegan honeymoon which is you know
you take someone who's been on a
standard American diet they're eating
KFC McDonald's etc and they switch from
that to a plant-based diet well of
course they're gonna feel better they've
gone from eating absolute crap to real
foods yes and so for a period of time
they're going to feel better for sure
but then what happens over a longer
period of time you know so I'm not
getting enough protein just in terms of
quantity and not getting the right
quality of protein that starts to have
an impact micronutrient deficiencies you
know vitamin A zinc calcium iron things
like that take a while to develop so
you're not going to see that decline in
performance happen right away it might
take three months it might take six
months might take nine months it depends
on all kinds of factors genetics health
status going into it the type of
exercise and activity that they're doing
the way they're implementing the diet
etc so you have to not just look at what
happens a month after someone goes vegan
you have to look at what happens six
months a year after or two years after
there was a couple that adopted child
from Russia and they thought as a child
was a little kid and it turned out she
might have been thirty they don't know
how old she was she tried to kill them
she's scared there was a [ __ ] horror
movie story it's not they're adopting a
little kid like a six-year-old that's a
[ __ ] 30 year old with some sort of a
metabolic disease yeah well that serves
you right for trying to be a do-gooder
you know they'll never do anything again
for anybody they'll never do one thing
the husband will try to bring it up
she's like [ __ ] you I mean the idea that
there are midgets dressing up as
children and trying to burrow into
family so that they can wake up in the
middle of night and kill them yeah is
truly the funniest thing that has
happened in in technically a [ __ ]
folks is something else
well she okay me whatever she was she
has like a growth disorder that keeps
her like looking like a small child you
see there was a video recently where it
looked like a kid was getting thrown off
a bus it was just it was it him it was a
like a little person who's just thrown
off a but it was it was it was a scam
like hey we got Ari and I both got duped
I got do because my friend texted me to
go through some had a file [ __ ] too
just got thrown off a bus it is
hilarious it's the funniest thing ever
when when the unzips the hood and you
see there's like grown-up face there's a
woman who looks like what the Fox does
think yeah we're in on it no I don't
think they knew the people on the
outside yeah I think the guys threw that
guy off the bus and that was the scam
yeah and then the dude who is this the
little person in the hoodie he was in
the scam on the scam but I don't think
the people on the street were in on so
now what happens when that when that
when the when he's these little people
wake up and they're like activated
they're like I'm gonna kill the family
how do they try to kill them well this
lady she was threatening she was
threatening to kill the family and they
were really worried that she was gonna
do that she was gonna poison them or
something like that he has what was the
scary stuff
it's horror movie because you know you
got to think who knows what kind of
abuse this little kid had gone through
well actually a 30 year old Raz as a
little kid through in Russia you know
and all these foster homes and foster
care and you know they are [ __ ]
ruthless over it's it's rough that's
rough I imagine it's not the best place
to grow up as a person with a disorder
what's up Jamie all right I feel like
I'm hearing are you saying that happened
in retro is a Russian kid Russian kid
okay this has happened in Indiana yeah
it's actually Ukrainian kids
Ukraine is part of Russia it's okay
isn't it yeah it's fine
they had it there robbery years before
they found figured this out oh my god
now what kind of what were those three
years nice like with their nice memories
good isn't that odd to look back and be
like remember when we all went to Disney
World
no they're probably like hey this [ __ ]
isn't growing I think they said that she
was creepy in the article that I read I
think they were actually like they would
wake up and see her like standing at the
door like I think there were things that
she did that yeah very very bad
[Applause]